notre page rétro maintenant tous les
soirs vous savez nous vous proposons une
petite balade 20 ans en arrière que se
passait-il à paris en août 73 et bien
cet été là on a pu voir pour la première
fois à la télévision un débat sur la
prostitution
la grande question d'époque c'était de
savoir s'il fallait rouvrir les maisons
closes au moment où en allemagne les
eros center faisait un tabac
et sur ce plateau de télévision eh bien
on retrouver justement marthe richard
dont le nom était associé à la fermeture
des maisons closes pierre duclos
aussitôt que la nuit des temps on ne va
pas c'est faux
oprean du poggio présent
images récentes chansons des années 30
interprété par fréhel et dans
l'intervalle débat sur la prostitution
en août 1973 la deuxième chaîne de
télévision faisait l'événement en
réunissant sur ce thème une
représentante du plus vieux métier du
monde et marthe richard désormais
favorable à l'ouverture de maisons
closes jadis fermé
grâce à elle puisqu'on ne peut pas
empêcher la prostitution elle existe
depuis tout le temps
alors puisqu'il y en faut mais ton pour
le moins le moindre mal et ça c'est le
moindre mal et mieux que de les bars les
femmes aux portes des hôtels dans les
rues voilà pourquoi il faut modifier
certaines lois
et voilà pourquoi vous devez contacter
mais oui vous l'avez fait fermer à moi
de les trouver mais c'est pas facile à
moi je préconise que deux maisons soient
construites mais pas une maison seul nom
de petites maisons dans un monde rit oui
où elles vont uniquement travailler
voilà en somme vous êtes en train de
monter un syndicat des dames de petite
vertu pas de syndicat les syndicats sont
toujours but politique une association à
but non lucratif parce que je veux dire
une corporation sont les groupes et
ensemble on a plus de plus de deux fois
deux points wii que si on est isolé
chacune de son côté à se tirer dans les
pattes et à ne pas savoir comment faire
on a aussi nos petits problèmes à
discuter ne serait ce par exemple que
s'il faut augmenter le tarif
selon le coût de la vie pourquoi vous
prostituées vous - très bien parce que
c'était le seul moyen que j'avais gagné
de l'argent de subvenir aux frais
d'éducation monfils
et puis de vivre de vivre indépendante
de tout le monde n'est pas mon france
contre son chef de famille et qu'elles
doivent se débrouiller avec puissant 930
paroisse pouvez toujours courir avec des
enfants encore c'est une vocation une
vocation pour le site faut-il vous dire
la vérité
faut-il vous dire que toutes ces filles
ont horreur de cela pour ne pas reculer
devant
que sale et dégoûtant plus qu'elle se
tape des crises de nerfs
le jour le soir quand elles travaillent
là les jo